the protests even reached Rio de
Janeiro's most affluent neighborhood on
Friday LeBlanc demonstrators blocked
traffic and tried to get to the home of
the Rio state governor they said they
would wait until he spoke to them and
after days of silence President juma
husa finally addressed the nation how's
Bonnie fist on this week's
demonstrations have taught us important
lessons transport fares have been
reduced and the demands of the
demonstrators have become a national
priority as those gang are really
diverse ronal the president said her
government would create a public
transport plan and would invest oil
revenues in education in her 10-minute
broadcast she also said she would
encourage state governors and municipal
officials to sit down with
representatives of the protest groups
and trade unions to discuss their
concerns reactions were largely positive
the President may have lost touch with
the general public a little but I think
she did a really nice job with her
address today sure manifest our soldiers
so just think about the proposed fee if
we have money to build nice stadiums we
have money for health and education and
to run the country well demonstrations
are expected to continue over the
weekends but some observers say they may
subside now that the president has
spoken